[Music]
Somehow this house is noisy these days,
people who aren't me are coming
This isn't always a sleeping pill, isn't it?
If you don't identify it, it's the
rumored Haru-chan.
I'm not fatter than I expected today. I'm
sure I can get my weight back soon.
I thought it was the temperature, but it's
definitely on top of this, but the
guard is unusually hard.
[Music] There's
this love.
It's the same
nan
Hmmmm
2 type o
[Music]
Hmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmm  I
feel nostalgic